The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
GANG CHEN: A brief recap
of the last lecture,
what we talked about is the
wave nature, wave particle
duality starting from
Planck, Einstein, relations.
Energy is related frequency.
Momentum is really to the
wavelength of the particle.
And that lays the foundation
for the wave particle duality.
Although Einstein focused
his effort on the photons.
And later on this was
extended to the, say,
the material waves.
And for material waves, we have
different ways to describe it.
There are different approaches--
metrics approach, the
operator approach.
But the one that I use here
is the Schrodinger equation
that says, describe this
wave function, which is
a function of time and space.
And the wave function on the
left hand side, essentially
this is like your
kinetic energy.
This is a potential energy.
And the right hand side
is a time dependent term.
And the solution, as we
will see in today's lecture
of this equation, will give
you a wave type of solution.
And what's interesting is the
meaning of this wave function
was not clear at the time that
this equation was written down.
So then it turns out
that the explanation,
correct explanation,
of the wave function,
wave function itself,
is a complex number.
Doesn't have physical meaning.
But the wave function
times complex conjugate
will give a real number.
And this gives the probability
of finding this material wave
at certain time and location.
So this is the explanation
given by Bourne.
And that created
a lot of trouble
because that means everything is
uncertain in the quantum world.
There's a probability, so
there is an expectation value,
the mean value.
And there is also
standard deviation.
And that standard deviation
to the Heisenberg uncertainty
principle we come under
in the last lecture.
And then we did a
little bit mass.
We say OK, let's do a
separation of variable.
Because this wave function, it's
a function of time and space,
as long as this U,
potential energy that
constrain this material wave.
So the equation is,
if you look at this,
the first term is
a kinetic energy.
The second term is
the potential energy.
And what's different
for each problem
is really this potential energy.
The constraints are different.
So if U is not
dependent on time,
then we can do
separation variable
to separate the wave function
into a space part and the time
part.
Time part was easy.
You can use it to solve it.
And it turns out that separation
of variable constant, E,
has a physical meaning.
And that meaning is the
energy of the system.
And with that, we substitute
into from this time
dependent equation we
can get the steady state
equation, where
the steady state is
space dependent part of the
wave function can be determined.
And you see that
this is actually
an eigenvalue equation.
It's here, here, on
the right hand side 0.
So what you actually use is not
only find the wave function,
but also find the eigenvalue,
of the energy of the system.
So this will put a constraint
on the possible energy
of a system.
That's where the energy
quantization word naturally
came up.
So this is where we were
in the last lecture.
And today we will
use this equation
and give a few simple solutions.
So today what we're going--
first I will give
example solutions.
And if you recall, in
the first two lectures,
we talk about what's the
energy of a molecule.
We have kinetic energy.
We have vibrational
energy, rotational energy,
electronic energy.
And I'm going to use the quantum
mechanical Schrodinger equation
to say what are the
Schrodinger equation quantum
mechanics imposed on this energy
forms and the quantization.
And then from this we will
say some important concept.
What is the quantum state?
And what are the degeneracy?
And if you'll recall that we
talked about the the counting.
We say, OK, how many
particles we have.
And this degeneracy
is an important step
in doing the correct
accounting when we later on do
the transport problem.
So count how much energy
the system really has.
So let's start with
the example solutions.
And we said the difference
for each problem
is really that potential U. The
first part is a kinetic energy.
Once you know the mass,
that's a term you have.
And each problem, each
particle, is constrained
by different potentials.
Our air molecule in this
room, electron in a film,
or the vibration
energy, those are
different potential constraints.
So let's look at the
first, the simplest one.
There's no potential, no
constraint of free particle--
complete free.
And let's look at 1D.
So we don't need to write
a three dimension, so
1D free particle.
What does that tell you?
So we have, already,
the time dependent term.
And so we only need to go to
find out from the steady state
the space dependent term.
By combined together, we know
what's the wave function.
And if it's free,
there's no constraint.
This U, the potential
energy is 0 everywhere.
And so my steady state equation,
if you copy that into 1D,
is minus h bar squared 2m, d
plus i, dx minus E plus psi
equals 0.
E is the energy
of this particle,
the eigenvalue of the problem.
And this equation I think
you can all solve it.
Let's go one more step.
I put them together,
this constant.
So what I have is k
squared plus psi equals 0.
Well, this K squared is 2m
E divided by H bar squared.
That's just a notation
for my [INAUDIBLE]..
And I solve this equation second
order, differentiable equation
with the constant coefficient
k, not a space dependent term.
That's the easy one.
So you find the
characteristic root
of this characteristic equation.
That's a plus minus k.
So what we have is the
psi x is a, E minus
ikx plus b e plus ikx.
Do you agree?
That's the solution.
Now we combine this
space-dependent solution
with the time-dependent
solution minus iE h bar.
So that's a time-dependent.
And the E, I say it's the
energy, E equals h nu.
So I could write this--
so the wave function as a
function of time and space
could be then written as an
exponential minus i omega t
plus kx plus b exponential
minus i omega t minus kx.
Well, this E equals h bar omega.
H bar is h over 2 pi.
So this is angular
frequency rather than nu.
Omega is 2 pi nu.
So that's the solution for
this free particle in space,
from minus infinite
to plus infinite.
What you can say is this
solution tells you--
the particle is a wave.
This is a typical wave.
This is a wave propagating
into which the direction?
Negative direction, x direction.
Omega kt minus kx.
Here is omega t plus kx.
So you have two
counter-propagating waves
in free space.
And that's go from minus
infinite to plus infinite.
The particle is everywhere.
This is the uncertainty
for free particle.
You can't pinpoint where it is.
And so, that's
the free particle.
And basically, it
tells us it's a wave.
And if you look at this,
k is the wave vector.
If you look at this wave,
And if I go to combine
and write a energy, what's
the energy of this particle?
Is h plus square k
square divided by 2m.
Here, this is my definition
for k. k is a wave vector.
I write the energy--
h bar k, go back to
the Einstein relation.
Here, p equals h
lambda is h bar k.
That's the momentum.
So it comes back to
essentially the p square 2m,
that's the kinetic energy
free particle, kinetic energy,
momentum energy relation,
energy equals 1/2 mv squared.
So this is the 1D free particle.
And now let's put
a constraint on it.
So 1D quantum well.
And we already went to the web
and look at the people actually
working on quantum wells.
So they deposit thin films.
And in that case, the
electron in the film
is subject to the constraint.
Because outside the film is
a vacuum or another material.
So now, we give the
simplest potential form
for a say, constraint,
simple constraint.
So here is the potential.
Let's say, this is the film.
If I deposit a solid film.
And this is the thickness
0 to D. And potential,
let's say I take this
as 0, this as infinite.
So that's a simplification.
The real case, vacuum
may not be the difference
between a vacuum and the film.
The energy is a pretty much the
work function of the electron,
we said before.
That's a few electron volts.
So it's not a 0 to infinite.
But for simplicity
of my solution
here, I say here is
zero potential, here
is infinite potential.
So what is the energy of the
electron or if it's a, say,
atom.
Somehow I constrain the atom
between two parallel plates.
What's the allowable energy?
If you recall two
lecture ago, we actually
gave a solution without
solving Schrodinger equation.
We say you have standing waves.
So we have a 1/2 wavelengths,
the full wavelengths.
With that, we found
the energy before.
And what are we're going to do
next is using the Schrodinger
equation and to derive the same
result. So here, energy is--
and here u is 0.
So for the 0 part, let's
suppose I take my coordinate
x is going to be
between 0 and D.
So between 0 and D, if you look
at the Schrodinger equation,
is essentially the same equation
because the potential is 0.
And then, outside this region,
because potential is infinite,
so what's the wave
function value?
This is infinite.
This has to be 0.
So my boundary condition,
essentially at these two
points, wave function is 0.
And in between, my
solution is here.
So I'm going to use
this boundary condition,
use the solution.
So we have-- the
solution is here.
I'm going to not
repeat that solution.
And in this case,
we have x equals 0.
Wave function should be 0.
And that tells me here when x
equals 0, this is 0, this is 1,
this is 1, a plus b equals 1.
So I have a plus b equals 1.
That's the first--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
GANG CHEN: Oh, 0.
Sorry.
a plus b equals 0.
Thank you.
Yep.
And x equal to D wave
function is 0 again.
So I have a exponential
minus ikx plus d, ikD, plus b
exponential plus ikD equals 0.
So a equals minus b.
So if a equals minus b,
I substitute in this.
What I have?
I take that out.
I will have a negative
2 ai sine kD equals 0.
After I substitute the
first a equals minus b,
that's what I have.
So I cannot have a equals
to 0, b equals to 0.
If I have that, my wave function
is 0, I have nothing there.
So my only way to have this
meaningful is sine kD equals 0.
And that means k times
D now has to be integer.
Say, sine kD equals 0, those
are pi, 2 pi, every pi.
So now I have to put a subscript
n, because this is n times pi.
And the n could be 0 plus
or minus 1, plus or minus 2.
So those are the
mathematical solutions.
And this mathematical solution
tells me, kn now is quantized.
Kn is n pi over D. And that
kn is 2m En h bar square.
So 2m En h bar square.
So my energy becomes discreet.
So from here, I
solve for the energy
of this particular equals--
AUDIENCE: Square root.
GANG CHEN: Oh, should I--
yeah, square root, 1/2.
And I square that.
So is a pi square n square
and the h bar square,
and 2mD square.
So this is the energy
solution for the particle--
in the old days, it was
called the particle in box,
in the one-dimensional box.
And this, as I comment
before, was the simplest
quantized solution.
And it was simply a homework,
the first possible mathematical
demonstration, the simplest one.
And I say, in the '70s, people
starting actually laying down
atomically flat film and to
realize those simple solutions.
And now it becomes
a very standard,
as you can see from the last
time we show from website.
A lot of people are
doing those quantum well,
using this energy quantization
to make lasers, particularly.
And if you substitute-- because
the last time we used h.
So if you substitute h equals--
h bar equals h2 pi
over 2 pi, you'll
find that that solution
is identical to what
we gave before.
So the last time I
solved this problem,
we said the energy
quantization without any real,
say, solving the equation.
And now we solve the equation.
We show that it's identical.
So this is the eigenvalue.
And of course, with
the eigenvalue,
we can also go to
say for each n,
there is also a corresponding
phi n, the wave function.
And it's important I carry
this n number, the quantized--
the quantum number.
And so here, phi n,
you substitute back
into the solution
here, a equals minus b.
What we have is minus 2ia
and the sine n pi x over D.
And from this, you will
say, n should not be 0.
If n is 0, again, wave
function is everywhere 0.
There's no particle there.
And the symmetry also tells me
what really is meaningful is,
n equals positive 1, 2, 3.
So that's the quantum number n.
And how to determine this
a, the normalization?
So because this
is a probability,
so the probability of finding
the particle between 0 to D
is [? 1. ?] Because
that's the outside is 0
and inside must be somewhere.
So my normalization is 0 to D
cosine, and times the cosine n
complex conjugate Dx.
That should equal to 1.
I'm not going through the math.
You can find that a
equals i 1 over 2D.
And that means the wave function
equals 2 over D, sine m pi
x over D.
So if you go to read the book,
the example given in the book,
take this wave function.
Go to calculate what's
the average momentum.
What's the uncertainty
in the momentum?
And what's the position
of the particle,
what's uncertainty of the
position of the particle?
Because in the example,
which I'm not going through,
you will see, from that
you can actually show
is the Heisenberg uncertainty
principle is indeed the case.
Of course, it should
be in those examples.
So you can take any of
those n values and do that.
So what I want to
emphasize, this
is the 1D problem,
one-dimensional problem.
And 1D problem, I get a
one quantum number, n.
And what I'm going
to next show you
is, if I go to a
two-dimensional problem,
I'll get two quantum numbers.
So I'm doing simple extension
of the same problem.
Here is a film.
And let's say it's a wire.
This is now people are doing
all nanotechnology from film,
to wire, to dots, so
it's a 1D, 2D, and 3D.
3D is the actually 0D.
Because when you constrain
three-dimensional,
normally we have
3D bulk material.
But if you constrain
in three dimensions,
becomes a 0D problem.
So let's do a 2D problem--
2D particle or quantum wire.
So again, I do a square.
And if you want
to do a cylinder,
you have to go to a
cylindrical coordinate.
I'm not going to spend
much time on math.
I want to just tell
you the concept.
So let's say this is a 0D.
I can do a square wire.
You can also do a
rectangular wire, whatever.
And the outside is potential,
u is, again, infinite,
inside potential. u is 0.
So what's the energy of a
particle now inside this wire?
And we can go back and write
down the Schrodinger equation,
steady state
Schrodinger equation.
Outside this wire, because
the potential is infinite,
wave function is infinite--
no, is 0.
Wave function is 0.
And inside, u is 0.
So I have a 2D problem.
So I'm going to write down
the 2D differential equation.
So I have a partial
differential equation.
Again, let me move this
h bar squared 2m combined
with E to get the k squared.
So I'm jumping one step.
I'm going to write the
partial differential equation
in 2D steady state part is--
so this is my x-coordinate,
this is my y-coordinate equals k
squared psi equals 0.
And this k square is, again,
is 2mE divided by h bar square.
That's the consequence
I move this to here.
This is the equation
inside this region.
And the boundary
wave functions are 0.
So for this partial
differential equation,
again, you'll find that
k include the energy.
Energy will be an
actual eigenvalue
of the solution process.
And because the two-dimensional
partial differential--
and the way I do it,
separation of variable.
So I do want go
through it to show
you get two quantum numbers.
So this is accounting
the quantum states.
What is the quantum state?
That concept.
So now I say, OK,
my wave function
is a function of x and y.
And I do a separation
a variable.
So I separate that into a
function x, a function y.
And then, if I substitute
into the original differential
equation, I will get--
this is substituted in--
x Dx plus y Dy u squared
plus k squared equals 0.
This is after you substitute
the wave function into here.
You divide both sides
by this wave function.
And you say, because this
is a function of x only,
so this is a function y only.
This is k is a separation
of variable constant.
So your only way is this is a
constant, this is a constant.
So that will add up--
because this is a function of
y, this is a function of x,
this is a constant.
So each of this term
has to be a constant.
So my notation is, I have Dx
square equals minus kx square.
So this is minus kx
squared, minus ky square.
Add up together, that
gives me k squared.
So I have the first.
And if you look at the--
my boundary condition, what
are my boundary condition?
Either x equals 0, psi equals 0.
That also means
this at 0 must be 0.
Because y is any value.
And same as say x squared
D, I have D equals 0.
And you can write
the y equals 0.
This same argument that
we say, y 0 is 0, yD is 0.
And this problem now, if you
check with this two boundary
condition, this equation
is identical to what
we had before.
I didn't write--
it's really, you
go to look at the solution with
the same boundary condition.
Your solution is the same.
So what we'll have, based
on this boundary condition,
I'll get psi kx
times D equals 0.
That's what we are written
down for 1D problem,
sine kD equals 0 in this 1D.
Now is a k in the
x direction is 0.
And similarly, in the y
direction, apply this same,
you will get a sine
ky times D equals 0.
So those are the
solution requirement
that imposed my kx, ky.
So I'm going to find the--
what we have now is kx n.
That's my quantization
number, quantum number--
equals n pi divided
by D. And this, again,
includes 0 plus minus 1.
And ky, I don't use the same
n because the two directions
are independent.
I use a different
integer, l, let's say.
And that's l pi over D. And
this l equals 0 plus minus 1.
So after I substitute back
into kx squared plus ky squared
equals k squared, what I
have, k squared is 2mE--
now E is the quantum
number including
both n and l, h square.
That should equal kx squared.
Is n pi over D squared
plus l pi over D squared.
So now, you can say, I have
two quantum number n and l,
because I have two direction--
two degrees of freedom.
And corresponding to
this 2 column number,
I will also have
psi wave function
ln equals a constant say, ln,
and the sine n pi x over D
sine l pi y over
D. And again, you
can use the
normalization condition
to find the coefficients.
That's not important.
What is important
is now to recognize
that each set, l and n, when
l equals 1, n equals 2--
so when l equals 1, that's a
halfway in the x direction.
Or not a ln.
I should do nl to be consistent.
So when n equals 1,
that's a half-way
in x direction. l
equals 2, that's
a full wave, full period,
in the y direction.
And now, if I do
n equals 2, that
is a full period
in the x-direction.
And l equals y is a [? half ?]
period in the y-direction.
So there are two different
forms, two different quantum
state.
However, the energy
doesn't care.
n equals 1, l equals 2,
or n equals 2, l equals 1.
So these two quantum state
have the same energy.
This is the degeneracy.
That quantum-- this energy
level is degenerate.
So we have now the concept I
say, what is the quantum state?
Each wave function here
is a quantum state.
And then say, some
quantum state are
degenerate when they
have different quantum
numbers but same energy level.
And some of you are familiar
with the density of states.
And this is the original
density of states.
It's just when we
have many, we'll
conduct more in the terms
of density of states
rather than degenerate states.
So this are the--
all these mathematics
I'm going to use.
The rest of the solution
I'm going to give you.
Because let's say, you will
have more partial differential,
more involved solution of
partial differential equations.
But also, I'm going to show
you my way of doing that
without solving the equation.
I can do that pretty much
for all the problems.
So I say that's my contribution
to quantum mechanics.
Because-- OK.
So let's look at
some other problems.
We said, this one, you can
say is a particle in a box,
you can say it's a quantum well,
quantum wire, quantum dots,
or it's a atom.
It's a translational energy.
So they say kinetic
energy pod is a quantized.
And let's look at
the other examples.
We talked about
before, if I have
a diatomic atom,
like a hydrogen atom,
a hydrogen molecule,
a diatonic molecule,
then you have a vibrational
part of the energy,
you have rotational
part of energy.
So let's first look at
the vibrational part.
If you have a mass
spring system,
the force in the
harmonic spring picture
will have say, forced linear
proportional to displacement.
And we say the problem--
each problem is different
is because of potential.
So we need to find
the potential.
And the potential energy
is the derivative--
force is the derivative
of the potential.
That's always true.
So from here, I say
the potential energy
is 1/2 k x squared.
So this is the one that you
should put in the steady state
Schrodinger equation.
That's your potential now.
You go to solve that equation.
Now you can say,
it's complicated,
because my potential
is a function of x.
My coefficient is
no longer constant.
So solving this equation
actually is a lot of effort.
You have to go, say, a
lot more math than the one
that we talked before.
And but see, what
the end result?
It's a one-dimensional problem.
The variable is the x only.
So from that, I have one quantum
number, one degree of freedom,
one quantum number.
And the energy, it turns out,
quantization, one quantum
number equals h nu n plus 1/2.
And this nu is not different
from classical oscillator.
If you have spring mass
system, what's the frequency?
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
GANG CHEN: Square root
of the k over m and 2 pi.
So you could, of course, write
this h bar omega m plus 1/2.
So you can see now, the
difference between a quantum
and classical system is that
say, in a classical system,
your energy is just
arbitrarily determined
by the displacement--
amplitude of displacement.
In the quantum, the energy has
to be multiple of this h nu.
That's the vibrational
energy quanta.
And this 1/2 is the
zero point energy.
Zero point energy.
And it turns out,
say, this oscillator
is also valid for
the lattice when
we have a lot of
atoms in the solid
and when we have
electromagnetic wave,
it's also oscillator,
electromagnetic field
oscillator.
All the energy is this form,
h bar, omega n plus 1/2.
And this 1/2 is a reflection
of the uncertainty principle.
And it's very interesting.
This zero point energy
is also something
that related to the
van der Waals force,
and some people will say can
also relate to the missing
mass of the universe.
And there I can comment
more on this later.
So we have-- this is
the harmonic oscillator.
And the next one is rigid rotor.
So what I'm trying
to deal with is,
for example, is two hydrogen
atoms for a molecule.
I say, one mode of
energy storage--
energy is this atom vibrate
relative to each other.
That's vibrational, that's
harmonic oscillator.
And the other way of
storing the energy
is by rotation of the molecule.
And so, in that case,
I say rigid rotor, say,
just decompose
the problem as fix
the distance between the
atom, they will rotate.
And how many degrees
of freedom here?
The distance is fixed.
So r is fixed.
And they only see the
[? flight ?] in space.
So I have two
degrees of freedom.
So for our rigid rotor,
when I have a mass m1, m2,
and I fix the distance,
and the rotation is related
to the moment of inertia, which
is the m1, m2, and r squared,
r0 squared.
So that's a separation
between the atoms m1 plus m2.
And now, in terms of degree
of freedom wave function,
because it has two
degrees of freedom,
the wave function is lm--
this m is not mass.
When I use a subscript
here, that's an integer.
Everybody uses it.
So you have to
distinguish yourself.
So lm integers.
And of course, I have two,
because I have theta phi,
two degrees of freedom.
And I'm not going
to write-- this
is a spherical
coordinate problem
and the solution is
pretty complicated.
But later on, you will see,
I'll go to website and show you.
It's much better than
I draw on the board.
And so, because of the wave
function two column number,
I have also the energy.
But now, the energy
is degenerate.
So I'm not using the
concept I just mentioned.
It turns out for I have
several combination of l and m
that can give you
the same energy--
El.
Energy only depends on l.
Wave function has
two quantum numbers.
And so, Elm, and you say,
it doesn't depend on 2i, l,
l plus 1-- doesn't depend on m--
rotational energy level.
And this quantum number,
l equals 0, 1, 2.
And that's a solution of
the Schrodinger equation.
In fact, in this case,
is the angular momentum.
And n constraint is the
absolute value is less than l,
less equal to l.
So what does it have is, if
you have wave function 0, 0, l
equals 0, m is only 0.
Now, if wave function l equals
1, then m is minus 1, 0 plus 1.
l equals to 1, minus 1,
cosine 1, 0, cosine 1, 1.
You see this free wave
function have the same energy.
And to just give you a heads
up what this wave function look
like is dumbbell shape.
And so, now we have the
degeneracy for any energy level
l quantum number is 2l plus 1.
Because here, m is 2l plus 1.
For any l, I give
M, is 2l plus 1.
That's my degeneracy.
So now I'm counting the quantum
state and the degeneracy
for energy levels.
And this is the rotation.
We said, first one is
translation, vibration
rotation.
If you think about atom,
there's another one
that's the electronic.
So let's go to the
electronic energy level.
And the simplest
electronic picture
is, I have a hydrogen atom,
one say, proton, one electron.
So we have one nuclei.
Nuclei is a much more
heavier than electron.
So it can be considered
as stationary.
And now, the electron will
orbit around the nuclei.
So before we say the force
between two charge, what's
the force, Coulomb force?
Force between two charge?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
GANG CHEN: So q1, q2,
q1, q2, and 4 pi epsilon,
that's a dielectric
constant, r square.
So here is the separation.
And of course, again,
if you integrate this,
you get the potential.
The potential is the
first derivative,
what we have written there.
So the potential for this
problem, u as a function of r
is minus c1 r, because of
the charge is the opposite.
So that's say, and then
there's a negative sign
in the potential.
So when they bound very close,
they go to lower potential.
So that's the direction there.
Given this potential, if
you look at this problem, 1D
or 3D problems?
Electron moving
around the nuclei?
Huh?
AUDIENCE: It's 3D.
GANG CHEN: It's a r,
it could be angular.
So we have three
degrees of freedom.
And my wave function
is a function
of r is function of
theta, a function of phi--
spherical coordinate--
three-dimensional.
And then I'm expecting
three quantum numbers.
So I'm expecting three
quantum number, n, l, m.
So now I have the
three quantum number.
And each [? shell-- ?] each
combination of quantum number
give me one quantum state.
But if you go to solve the
problem for energy eigenvalue,
you find that depends on n only.
So although I have many
quantum state, and my energy
En is a function.
So nlm, but it doesn't
depend on the lm.
So what I have is the mass
of the electron c1 square,
and 2 h bar square n square.
And if you plug
in the number, you
find this one is 13.6 electron
volts divide by n squared.
So this is the energy
depends on n only.
See, the wave function
has three quantum number.
And what are the constraints
for those quantum numbers?
Here I have n integer 1, 2.
And l has to be less than
n, has to be positive.
So when n equals 1, l equals 0.
m is the same constraint
I have for this problem.
So m is equal or less than l
So this is the energy level.
And if we look at the
wave function n equals m
and then I have l equals 0--
1, 0, 0-- n equals 1.
And then when I have n
equals 2, l could be 0.
In that case, m is 0.
Or I can have wave function
equals 2, l equals 1.
Because when n equals
2, I have 0, 1.
And then, in that case
I have 2, 1, 0, 2, 1, 1.
So the degeneracy gn
for any, let us say,
n value is n squared.
n equals 1 is a one
[? wave ?] function.
n equals 2, that's a four
[? wave ?] functions.
If I say, n equals
2, I have one energy,
I have with four wave
function have the same energy.
So almost.
I'm almost there, and counting.
But before I do
that, I want to say,
my way of solving the
Schrodinger equation.
I didn't solve it.
So now I'm going to show my
hand-waving way of solving it.
I give you one example, and you
can do the others, probably.
I said that, in the previously,
when we do the quantum wells,
the wave is either
half wave or full wave.
That's my boundary condition
to form standing waves.
So this one we're
already gone through.
And we said that's consistent
just based on the standing wave
requirement.
When we do the
oscillator, my potential
is like this, 1/2 kx squared.
That's my potential.
We said that each
problem, what distinguish
the problem of energy
is really its potential
and its corresponding
boundary conditions.
Because of the other
terms look same
in the Schrodinger equation.
So now, I look at my--
this is my x.
This is my potential, u.
I say, what will be
the wave function
under this constraint--
the potential constraint?
Again, I'm going to make this
hand-waving standing wave
requirement.
I don't even know the
boundary, it has to be 0.
In fact, it's not exactly 0.
So my solution will
not be exactly correct.
But I'll just say, now I
still have my standing half
wave, a full wave.
And this is the boundary
here, this is my xn.
And now you say, 2xn is
halfway, must be multiple--
those [? nods ?] of
the wave, the endpoint,
where a clamp is at the
boundary constraint, has to--
so here, I have 2xn.
So that's the wave, must
be lambda times 2 times n--
multiple of half wave.
That's my requirement.
And what does it tells me?
It tells me, xn equals
4 over n, h bar--
h over xn-- no--
xh over p, because
lambda is h over p.
I change a wavelength
into momentum.
And now, from here, I have
the p, so p in terms of xn.
I will just argue that
the kinetic energy
of this particle
in the oscillator
equals potential energy.
So that's what's
the kinetic energy
is p square 2m equals potential
energy, 1/2 kx squared--
kxn square.
p, I have the here
in terms of xn.
And from there, I can
find out from this,
I substitute the p into here.
I can find the xn.
So xn square equals
mk and nh over 4.
And now, I go-- because
this is my xn, my En--
energy is a kinetic energy
plus potential energy.
I say they are equal.
So the energy En
equals kxn square.
So equals kxn square.
And you substitute it in.
And what I have is
a 4 nh k over m.
And per-- my format
is pretty close.
If you look at the
harmonic oscillator,
the real solution is
En is h nu times n.
So the point is,
this quantum number
is a linear
[? proportional ?] to En.
You see there?
My potential, because of
a potential constraint,
it changed my
quantum quantization
is proportional to n.
And in the case of a quantum
well, this one you say
is proportional to n squared.
You go back to look at your
En is proportional n square.
In this shape, the
En change into n.
And in the electronic potential
that we just covered here,
here is 1 over r.
You change it over n into
the denominator square.
So my point is, all
those problems are really
defined by the potential
of the particle.
That's the constraint.
And in fact, I try that
the electronic, I can also
make the same kind of argument.
I get 1 over n squared.
I can't get that 13.6 correct,
but I can get 1 over n square.
I haven't found out how I
do this spherical problem,
get an l plus l times l plus 1.
Maybe someone can figure it out.
That's an angular
momentum problem.
So now we have solution
for translation.
We have vibration rotation
electronic for atoms.
So we almost have everything.
But have one thing that's not
even in classical mechanics.
And this is the spin.
It's not even in the
Schrodinger equation.
You have to go to
relativistic consideration
to get that additional spin.
So I'm not going
into spin in detail.
It took me actually a long
time to have some idea
of spin complete quantum.
So I have next is a spin.
So when we solve a problem
like a rigid rotor,
the rotor is rotating,
rotating about a certain axis.
That's an angular rotation.
That's the classical-- you
have a classical analogy.
Let's say, there is an intrinsic
property of any particles,
mature waves there, and
that's an intrinsic, say,
angular momentum.
And that angular momentum is
characterized by the spin.
And turns out, spin of
electrons and photons,
phonons, they are different.
Electron has a 1/2
spin, and the photons,
phonons have integer spin.
And because of this difference,
they obey very different rules.
So let's say, electron spin.
And the quantum number for
electron spin we use the s.
And there are only two,
positive 1/2, negative 1/2.
So those two quantum
numbers, you can get it--
you cannot get it from
solving Schrodinger equation.
So I'll just artificially
add into the wave function
that we say, for example, when
we consider any wave function
quantum number,
we'll add an s here.
That's important
for me to count.
And for photons and phonons,
and later on phonons,
s is an integer--
integer 1, s equal 1.
And it turns out, for
the 1/2 spin particles,
the statistics is very
different than the integer
spin particles.
And for this 1/2
spin particle, we
have Pauli exclusion principle.
So now if you go
to say, my quantum
state for that electron, we
just considered the electron
problem.
The electron I have nlm.
And now, I add an s.
s equal plus 1/2 or minus 1/2.
So I originally, for nlm,
that's a gn square degeneracy.
Now because of s, I have
2n square degeneracy.
So this one, what the Pauli
exclusion principle say,
is each quantum state--
for this 1/2 spin,
each quantum state
can have maximum one particle.
So that's the-- see, it
does not apply to phonon,
does not apply to photon,
because they have integer spin.
But applied to
electron, each quantum
state you can only
have maximum one.
So because of this,
photons, electrons,
they behave very differently.
And this, electrons is
a fermion from Fermi.
And photons are boson from Bose.
Electron don't like each other.
And photons, photons you can
take as many as one quantum
state.
So this gives me for
the case for here,
particle or say, electron,
you can say the degeneracy now
is gn equals 2n squared.
It doesn't change the energy
level because of the spin
unless you go to
very, very detail.
But that's fine.
But just 2n square,
that's a degeneracy.
Now I've gone through all
this, you say, what's the use?
Why are you going through this?
So what we say [INAUDIBLE]
is this lecture,
we want to understand--
at least appreciate--
the energy are quantized
in the mature waves.
Electrons, translation
energy, vibrational energy,
rotational energy, electronic,
all those are quantized.
They become discrete.
And we also emphasize
that depending
on the degree of freedom,
we have quantum numbers.
And quantum state
could be degenerate
if their energy is the
same, but they are actually
different quantum states, they
have the same energy levels.
So let's go to real world, say,
where we observe those quantum
effects.
And if you look at, say, how
the quantum mechanics started
was actually from a
black body radiation
and also explaining the hydrogen
spectrum, so observations.
And very clearly, because
energy levels in the matter
is discrete, and
when it interact
with the other particles.
For example, a photon interact
with the molecular electronic
energy level.
And let's say, the solution we
have for the electronic energy
level is negative 13.6
n square electron volts.
So n equals 1, that's
one energy level.
n equals 2 is higher.
So let's say, this is n
equals 1, this is n equals 2.
And so, when a photon-- whether
a photon interactive or not
depends on the
photon energy match
to this energy level or not.
Because when an
electron in hydrogen--
they first stay in the
lowest energy level.
And the photon
energy, if it comes
to match so that it goes to the
next level, it gets absorbed.
If it's in between, it
doesn't get absorbed.
If it's too high,
So what I'll say, is you say
discreet absorption lines.
And in fact, if you go to
check the solar spectrum
of the sunlight going
through the atmosphere,
you see many discrete lines.
And that's because the
atoms have discrete energy
and they absorb photon
of different energies.
So that's one example.
And what I want to do go
next is go to the website
and let's look at this online.
And then also, periodic
table that's fully--
[INAUDIBLE] absorption.
So let's start first step
with the solar spectrum.
Maybe this is a good picture.
We'll see how good it is.
Here you can see.
This is sunlight.
I think this is a black
body from the equivalent.
And the yellow is
outside the atmosphere.
And once it goes
through the atmosphere,
it become very discrete.
And in this short
wavelength, so now
you have to learn how to convert
the wavelengths into energy.
And wavelength times frequency
equals speed of light.
So if you know wavelength,
you know frequency.
And frequency is h nu--
energy.
Energy, if you convert
further into electron volts,
and one electron volt is
equivalent to 1.24 micron.
So that's the-- so
here is about 1.24,
that's where one electron
volt. Shorter, higher
energy of photon,
[? longer, ?] lower energy.
So here, you go to this part.
It's electronic.
Because the vibrational
energy, rotational energy
don't have that high energy
to interact with the photons.
So it's really the electrons
in the molecule or atom
absorb the photon.
Once you go to
here, on this side,
it's a rotation and vibration.
Rotation is actually
a very small energy.
And vibration is
a higher energy.
So actually, what the
molecule do, for example,
when it vibrate, also rotate.
So that's why, actually, it
depends on your resolution
and equipment.
If you do very high
resolution, you
can actually see discrete
lines of rotation vibration.
And there are many, many lines.
And there are many
species in the atmosphere.
They overlap with each other.
So you can see, it's the
quantum mechanics doesn't
have to be going into nano.
And it's actually in every day.
And let's go more.
First I want to show, those
are the solutions for the wave
function, how the wave function
in [? psi, ?] and when you do
[? psi and ?] [? psi ?]
complex conjugate,
what it really look like--
n equals 1 is a sphere.
n equals 2, you can say
it's like a dumbbell,
two [? half ?] [? blocks. ?]
And this is a--
when l equals 0,
it's a spherical.
When l equals 0, m has to be 0--
n, 0, 0.
That's only-- so and then plus
spin, then you have two states.
Spin, s, if I think about
electron, going into n
equals 1, then n equals
1 can have two quantum
states-- s equals plus minus
1/2, that it hasn't considered.
So this could be two spin--
two states, n equals 1.
N equals 2 is, I say, if I
add a spin, it's 2n squared.
So it equals 8.
n equals 2.
So each of these wave functions,
sphere, that's l equals 0.
Now l equals to 1, that's
a p orbital, that's
the atomic orbital, p orbital.
And when n equals 3, I
have a p orbital here.
And n equals 3, this
is, say, n 3, 0, 0.
That's an s orbital,
it's a spherical--
p orbital.
And then I have d orbital.
D orbital, you can say, it
has a five wave functions.
5 times 2 is 10.
So there are 10 possible quantum
states for the d orbital.
And 6 here, 2 here.
So what this bring you to?
This brings you to
the periodic table.
Now let's look at
periodic table.
If you come to my office--
you should come to my office.
I look at that every day.
And most of the
time, we feel there
should be more atoms there.
Can't find it.
So start from
hydrogen, n equals 1.
Helium, n equals 1.
There are two spin,
[? up, spin down. ?] So now
let's look at the [? filling. ?]
So n equals 1, I have hydrogen,
could be spin up or spin down,
n equals 2 is helium.
Now, the next n is
a 13.6 divided by 4.
So it's a higher-- a few
electron volts higher.
So now, I have nithium,
electoral n equals 2 now.
Berinium-- so now,
2n, say, s equals--
s orbital field.
And now I go to boron, carbon--
so I have boron,
carbon, the p orbitals--
three p orbitals.
So I can hold the
six more atoms.
So now you go to
here, go to helium.
So [INAUDIBLE],, why
say, [INAUDIBLE],, why
helium is so stable?
Because between here and
here is a few electron volts.
That's a large energy.
Remember, kt is 26
milli-electron volts--
milli.
So it's not active because
it takes a lot of energy
for the charge to go to the next
level, to fully taken there.
So you continue.
So anchor three, anchor
three I should have a--
say, I have anchor three,
I have p, I should have d.
But things start to change.
Because rather than d--
rather than if
you get potassium,
rather than going here, it
started with the less one,
the n equals 4.
What happens?
Is I say, well,
the solution I give
is one charge, one
nuclei, one charge.
And when you have a lot of
electrons, they will interact.
That potential will change.
So the solution was split.
They are not going exactly
to be equal to each other.
There are small
differences between those p
and the d levels.
And in fact, it turns out the
3D, which are here, this is 3D,
is less, say, energy than--
say, the higher energy
than for s orbitals.
So the charge always goes
to lowest orbital first.
And so, that's the--
those transitional
metals-- those
are the transitional
metals, are the d orbital.
And then once you go to
here, the f orbital comes in.
Very complicated once
you go all those, say,
wave function and
complex wave functions.
If you do catalysis,
that this is a-- say,
thermo-electrics people
look into this all the time.
So we'll stop here.
And pretty much with
this full lecture,
I went through the
quantum mechanics.